un match à vite oublier pour les
templiers d'elancourt ce samedi les
élans courtois se sont fait submerger
sur leur terrain par les dauphins de
nice à l'occasion de la 3e journée du
championnat élite
le score est sévère 33 13 les dauphins
sont pas venus ici de nice pour faire un
match nul ou pas de match ils sont venus
ils étaient motivés mais c'est une
équipe explosive
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de joueurs donc
je vous sors intensité et joue ensemble
on s'est pas réveillé dans les cinq
minutes ya eu cinq actions donc en deux
et c'est donc après c'est dur de revenir
c'est une bonne équipe il faut le
respecter mais nous on a on arrêtait
plein d'occasions on a beaucoup plus de
talent et le potentiel que ce qu'on a
montré ses seins
après cette contre performance les
templiers pour à la quatrième place du
classement avec un bilan de deux
défaites et une victoire pour expliquer
ce début de saison en demi teinte les
cadres pour être le manque d'assiduité
aux entraînements on joue comme on
s'entraîne
dernièrement on a pas fait des supers
entraînements et ça se voit son terrain
si on veut performer
vous avez mon entraînement plus de
discipline ce cas en devenir prochain
match pour les templiers d'elancourt le
dimanche 13 mars sur le terrain des
cougars de saint-ouen-l'aumône champion
de france 2015 et invaincus depuis 17
matches